欢迎收看理财大人秀的教学单元
歌有仇必报
强势回归第二季了
但今天可能不是叫做歌有仇必报
今天叫做歌唇鼓debug
大家知道吗
即使是看筹码的小歌
他有一块是做唇鼓
但是当然不可能跟我们鼓鱼一模一样
所以小歌的唇鼓方法
今天要来大公开大揭秘
他的方法是用个股期货
很多人就花一个大问号
期货不是高杠杆高波动吗
怎么能够拿来存股
所以小哥把他取了一个新名字
叫做累存股
古瑜听着想
对啊 因为你比较累啊
好 为什么小哥会累
女人不要让小哥太累
今天就来跟大家分享
小哥的存股方法
用个股期怎么存股
而且风险不会像你想的那么大
又能每年帮你省下很多存股的钱
好 这边来请问小哥了
为什么要加个累呀
你是多累
这个累一点
然后呢比较多钱
累一点比较多钱
没有 我还是要评估多累
一个月只要动一次
一个月动一次吗
我觉得好少
太少
一个礼拜要七次就对了
你没看那个
珍妮佛罗培兹
最近跟班艾弗列克复合吗
不是有签一个条约吗
一个礼拜至少要四次
要四次
累吗
四次真的是有点累
好
那这个一个月一次而已
这个我跟古鱼讲过
他说一个月一次
好累
古鱼到底一年
有没有再动一次
所以我跟他讲很多次了
他每次讲的时候
他说兴致勃勃勃
兴致勃勃
好像被你点燃了什么火这样
对 她说哇 你这么好
然后过一段时间问她说
你那你开始了吗
没有 我忘记了
所以其实我觉得
古旗类存股真的蛮多优点
好
那首先我们来看
第一个资金效率化
好
刚刚赵宏有提到杠杆
那杠杆是这样子的
杠杆要不要开
纯粹看你个人
是
古期的杠杆呢
这一开就7倍
7倍的杠杆
一开7倍
但是呢
你不要all in
不要all in就不是7倍了
你拿一点点钱出来
有可能就是你的杠杆呢
有可能是没有杠杆
或是只有2倍而已
所以呢
这我们类存股
我们都会说
你大概开个2倍杠杆就可以了
是
因为你存的股票
通常有殖利率啊
那殖利率呢
这个不错的
又要腰斩
它是比较困难的
它是比较不会腰斩的
所以通常我们可以准备个50%的资金去存
那剩下50%的资金备用
只要股价腰斩的时候
你这50%资金再拿出来
你的期货就没有断头的问题
所以这样子存其实还是蛮安全的
但是我们还是一样提醒在前面
做个股期就是一个开杠杆的行为
不管两倍七倍都是杠杆
所以大家先评估
自己知道这个工具的风险再来用
不是只有好处
一定也是有风险
你每次你都要看一下
你股期的真正的部位到底有多大
你要看一下
你有可能入金100万
那事实上你在玩700万的东西
那你在玩700万的东西
假设你自有资金
闲置资金也有700万的话
那你就没开什么杠杆了
你假如说我闲置资金就这么100万
哇塞 你开了杠杆
而且开满了杠杆
可能会赔不起
那这种这个一个震荡就赔光了
这个就比较危险
那第二个
这也是股息很特别的地方
它获利可以领出
怎么领
这个每天下午2点一结算
一结算你就可以把钱给出金了
出金
那出金呢
这叫做获利可以领出
那这种呢
不用卖古旗就可以继续存
部位还在
那一般人像存股的话
像股员存股部位那么大
那你假如把这个钱领100万出来
他可能就要卖股票了
但是这个古旗类存股
他是不用把这个期货卖掉
只要你有获利
你就可以领出来
但是你要记得
你不是说领出来马上把它花掉
你领出来马上花掉
那万一跌回去的时候
那你要把钱再囤回去
所以这比较麻烦
那第三呢
每月有红利
好
这个就是今天要交的一个真谛了
对不对
我这个以前没有在讲这个的时候
每月真的都有红利
那你今天还要讲吗
不大想讲
因为现在有些股票已经没有红利了
反而要付出红利
付出红利就没办法存了
那就不要再转仓了
不要再往下存了
你就不要存了
你可能就要领出来
然后就可能改换成献股去存
因为有些标的
其实在月初的时候
还是有红利可以领
但到现在就没有红利可以领了
等一下来教大家
什么叫做每月有红利
要教人家一下
光看字面可能看不太懂
对啊 你要看价差单
来看第四个呢
這個股利當天配息的話
像最近有些股票已經除全息了
像我今年參與了兩黨
一黨叫做台郡
一黨叫做創意
都不錯啊
創意是實力率沒那麼高
台郡還不錯
對啊 可是他們其實除息當天的表現
都是稍微開高一點點
後面就往下殺了
那這些呢
這一開盤你假如沒有賣掉的話
後面抱著可能又跌回去
不過創意比較漂亮
創意最近的關鍵分點滿很多
創意很強
所以最近它已經填息了
但是這種填息有些像創意你買股票的現金鼓勵還沒有拿到還沒啦 他会有个入账日还没还没通常都要半个月到一个月但是我的鼓励我是当天就领到了
这么好
当天权益数就配给你了
因为这个玩股票
其实你不是投资人
玩股票其实我们都说你是交易人
是 交易人
交易人
所以你的鼓励
它是配权益数给你的
那第五个
我們就看看就好
我們不要解釋太多
這個解釋太多不大好
觀眾知道有這個優勢
但我們不能跟您強調
免得小哥就被查水表
對 我被查水表就完了
不要解釋太多
大家知道 放在心裡
In your heart
好 來看這個
這個股息類存股的缺點
第一個
通常我們都說
你槓桿不要開太大
不要開太大
不過呢
這個只要有人賺錢之後
他就會開很大
對
都這樣
很像到那個國外花外幣有沒有
對
你會突然分不清楚那個錢
一碗拉麵折合台幣其實是500
但是你花日幣的時候沒感覺
對 因為這樣一樣啊
這個古奇呢
奇怪了
以前股票 好容易買
股票按的時候都會啪啪啪的
古奇怎麼可以一直按
感覺我的錢沒放很多
怎麼可以按很多
这就是这股息可以开杠杆的原因
那这种会导致怎么样
导致万一股价下跌
期货是这样子的
只要一下跌
它就扣你的权益数
扣一扣
只要扣你的权益数
假如低于76%
约翅保证金低于76%
它就会开始给你简讯
等于是有点断头的意思
要你补交保证金
所以杠杆开很大
你就常常接到简讯
交易去你就必须得处理
所以保证你假如放不够
你假如没有处理
它就会帮你砍仓
第三个
骨骑的流动性有的比较差
有的真的差
所以你不要说
小哥我想做这个存骨
怎么流动性那么烂
那我价差怎么做
你到底要做价差还是做存骨
我跟你讲
你讲了这句话
骨鱼讲的一模一样
真的
現股也是有流動性差的
很多人說我存股
你怎麼叫我存這種冷門股
你是怎樣 你是要買幾千張你
你是今天買明天賣你
很多人都問這個問題
我說你要買幾張
我這一張會不會賣不掉
拜託一張閉著眼睛砍都砍掉
你又不是要買幾千張
一樣 股期流動性不好
轉倉都沒什麼問題
但是你假如盤裝做價差
有的期貨價差真的不好做
所以真心想存在来
很多人刚才讲说
我跟你讲就是存股
然后跌下来就问你
小哥怎么办
存股不是跌下来
我们就要更开心
因为可以买更多
跌下来要很开心才对
那涨上去怎么办
涨上去不是太好了吗
对不对
涨上去不是就有获利吗
那获利
你假如认为殖利率下降到一个程度
因为你涨上去
你的殖利率一定会下降
下降到一个程度
你想获利了结那也OK啊
跌下来值率更高
那也非常好啊
所以存股呢
我们看股票都要保持一个
很乐观的态度
你现在了解股虞的心情了
对不对
对
有没有
他每天都嘻嘻哈哈的
有没有就上涨
吾吾开心啊
下跌吾吾开心啊
难怪每天看到他都是笑咪咪的
跟我们这些
做短线的
哎呦 今天被嘎了
对啊 好
那我来看一下
这个是我在我的粉丝团有贴的
好 其实几乎每天都update哦
对 每天update
那我最先开始贴呢
是在4月27号
那一天台股呢 跌蛮多的
是
那通常跌蛮多
我就特别喜欢贴赔钱对商单
因为人家看到你赔那么多
哇 你看哦
这个联发哥赔26
可成赔54
历程也赔 台湾也赔
就只有一个心复发
不过心复发这绿色什么意思啊
这是空单
空单我赚钱啊
空单赚钱了
因为那天大盘大跌啦
空什么心复发啦
因为
也不会觉得很好空啊
应该空个高波动电子啊
这个其实是在维持我的保证金
维持利用的
因为你只要放一个空单在里面
万一遇到系统性的风险
什么叫系统性风险呢
比如911
这太严重
举个别的例子
都很恐怖
那我隔天都是跌停的
去年的512
跌1000多点
今年512也是
现在遇到512都要特别闪开
明年511至少先把股票卖一卖
又到512了
先付空单
遇到系统性风险
这只要全面跌停的那一天
你只要有个空单在
你的股息比较不会被全面性的断头
所以各位你存股最好是摆几个空单
那我就摆了西木发
因为它可转在大幅转换
主力大幅的卖出
不过它直立也蛮漂亮的
我可能会在除菌期前先跑一趟
先跑一趟
这个除菌期后再把它建回去
好
这在4月27号贴的
那过了几天之后
这个损益回来了
各位看一下
我的联发科呢
这个均价是844
不过我经历过一个转仓
转仓之后我的均价呢
下降了
因为转仓之后呢
我是赔钱的
赔钱以实现损益变丑了
那我的未实现损益就变漂亮
那可曾转仓之后
我是赚钱的
所以你看到這個均價上升了
那可成的損益也變漂亮了
那這個新物發轉倉之後
它的價格變得很低
所以我的這個
與實現又變賠錢了
那剩下各位來看一下
這顏色變了原本多單原本都賠錢的後面變賺錢後面變賺錢歷程臺灣也是變賺錢那我的口數都固定我的可成81口
那到了5月份81口
6月份也是81口
一直到昨天
我的可成還在
好
也還是81口
其實大家也不要太care
這個損益的大變化
因為存股你是要很長期的
你要看長期的
当然因为这一波反弹
这些股票刚好都弹得蛮高的
所以小哥在损益上
就有明显的变多了
对不对
你现在看我损益变多
其实我的内心里面
还是有点担忧
因为等到有一天
例如说可存
假如万一跌回到150块
我的损益又会变得很难看
但是你在存股
你担忧什么呢
真的
贴出来就很难看
不过实际上还OK
你就不要贴了好不好
其实我们就是要
这个给投资人一个观念
是
我说存就是存
不要说是嘴巴想存
结果心里做的人手上做的是价差
所以我就贴了
到目前为止贴了一个半月
那我们来看一下
这过程中我就只有转仓
这边你看这边
这个过程是转仓
只有有一口不小心没有转仓
忘记转了
它就变交割
那这边有赚钱有赔钱
有赚钱有赔钱
一直到现在
刚好可诚搭上了最近的一波
投信大买
一档高股息的ETF
在换股
可诚就被买上来了
可诚也有十字库长股
那当初存它的原因
我觉得它的现金股利还不错
它每年都说每年可以配10块
他们公司钱最多
钱超多
联发科殖利率是比较漂亮
联發科存到現在
獲利也快到100塊了
還有利成 台虹
最近是比較扭的
不過他們的殖利益都還不錯
都很好
我們現在來一檔一檔
跟各位講一下
首先來看一下
低檔联發科
重點在你要講的是
你怎麼會選上他
對不對
來當你存股的標的
是
联發科各位看一下
在低檔
你看最低還有到797塊
跌破800塊
對 那我在800多塊的時候存
各位看一下 它的殖利有到7.85%
那時候在800塊的時候
殖利快到9%了 你知道嗎
所以它殖利非常高的
那殖利高了你還要特別看一下
你要看一下它的營收有沒有衰退
那聯發科的營收其實到目前為止
並沒有大步的衰退
不會 那小哥到Q4要注意
我知道
聯發科最近比較討厭的是
當我公佈了我的存股之後
有很多人来感谢我
你为什么感谢我
小哥我看你买什么
我跟着买什么
哎呀好可怕
我都在这样你不要感谢我
你要感谢你自己
因为你也是冒着风险的
对啊
冒着风险
好那因为很多人存的关系
导致最近联发科的价差单变丑了
也就是说联发科下个月的期货变高了
好
这边可能跟大家解释一下
小哥你不是先平仓
对不对
你不是用一般的转仓
对
你是在上面
其实因为你有告诉过我
有一个叫做价差
对 价差单可以有
这个大家要留意哦
对 价差单我们有空
再跟各位讲得更详细一点
好 那价差单呢
在上个月还不错 还是付的
对
这个月突然变成正的了
所以我的联发科
我可能最近会早一点
那怎么办
可能会趁结算那一天
因为结算那一天呢
就看有没有有机可乘
看能不能这个顺利的
这个转仓到下个月
沒辦法順利轉倉
我們說順利轉倉是說
轉倉的時候不要付出太多的成本
假如不用付出太多成本
我待還可以轉
不然就不要蠢了
改換成現股
所以你還是用價差嗎
還是說你乾脆先平倉去買遠月
要看當下的狀況
因為在結算那一天兵荒馬亂了
比較有機會
現在沒機會
這幾天都沒有機會
這幾天價差單都是兩塊半
2.5元很嚴重
因為聯發科你2.5元轉12個月
你要付出30塊
假設每個月轉都是這樣
都是變貴2.5元承受不起的
希望是短期現象
以前都是付的
這個月不曉得為什麼變成正的了
聯發科的籌碼其實也不錯
主力買 投信買
分點也在買
所以籌碼面 基本面看起來都不錯
所以當時我就存了聯發科
接下來是最近一直漲的可存
投信不停加
我們可存剛好貼的圖片
當時貼的位置就在這個地方
故意選在下通道的時候貼
讓大家看到賠錢
你小哥賠錢
賠錢說有存也真的有存
後面就一路漲上來
一直到昨天最高還有176.5
其實這段時間漲蠻多的
主力一路的大買
主力有誰
主力第一個有庫廠股
國安門庫廠股10到6月6號結束
第二投信
這就是00878的佈局
可能不只他們了
一次佈局很多天
以前看都是大概5天
不過這次佈局很多天
它殖利率因為它每年配10塊
所以通常這可乘我大概到200塊以上
到200块以上
它的值率会低于5%
那个时候就会比较想
可能会把它换成值率比较高的
那目前为止就会继续存
因为这种每年10块
我觉得这还不错
所以小哥真的在存股
当然可曾未来
有没有什么新的业务契机
就等公司自己来发布了
因为满手现金
总要早点事情做
可是你要想一个问题
它最近的营收是不是爆烂
因为它本来的厂卖掉
卖掉了
它卖给蓝丝科技
你知道賣給藍絲科技之後
它股價跌多好嗎
藍絲科技的股價 不是可成股價
當然因為他賣的廠也是代工型的
所以都不好
他賣毒蘋果給人家
藍絲科技股價腰斬再腰斬從40塊跌到剩9塊是 比可成自己己跌的還多哇塞我就覺得這個老闆英明洪老闆英明
但是還是得想企業的下一步
而且坊間其實有在說
他有在規劃
對
你要這樣想
可成現金很多
他只要隨便買一個廠進來
或隨便買一家公司進來
他未來的營收一定是成長的
是
所以未來營收成長的時候
哇塞
那時候股價可能就不只這樣
來 接下來看8039台虹
台虹的直率有到5.33%
最近籌碼也不錯
股價也沒有大漲
那這種我就比較安心存
是 穩穩的
價差單也是付的
所以每個月這樣轉
還有點紅利
好 接下來我們看這個6239的歷程
也是穩穩的測試股
直率更漂亮 6.85%
然後主力也是一路買
外資買 投信買
本點也在買
所以這是基本面跟籌碼面
都不錯的股票
好
其實小哥選的存股標的
也很單純啦
很單純
對 雖然有時候像聯發科
我個人就覺得不太是
一般會選存股
就古瑜可能不會選到這樣
對 波動比較大
但是其他的你說像
像剛講歷程這種的
它其實波動不大
對 蠻適合的
對 其實比較喜歡這種牛一點
這個聯發科之前存
也覺得蠻刺激的
我每天波動很大
對 好
那這個存股呢
通常存股的人他都會想參與除選席
對啊 你也是啊
因為最近又是除選席的忘記
所以我要特別講一下
除選席很多人都會用股票來
像谷魚他就專門用股票來參與除選席
對他來講這個優點的成交量大
不過這對谷魚來講不是什麼優點
也不重要 他很多股票成交量也很小
什麼天然氣瓦斯有沒有
對 根本不用care成交量
好 不过有些人他喜欢玩短线的
有些人喜欢今天买股票除息
明天早上去之后再卖掉
再买另外一档股票除息
那这种人就要考虑他的成交量
是
不过他的缺点
缺点也算是优点
就是一个好国民
还要缴很多所得税
还有健保补充费
要等到两三个礼拜才拿到股利
那股票结果的优点立马拿到股利
不受停资券影响
这很重要 不受停资券影响
对 这是很重要
喜欢放空的人真的很重要
缺点呢 成交比较小
还有正利价差的问题
还有换契约的问题
这比较麻烦
有的问问说
小哥那买全镇会有配息吗
不会
买全镇只会调整旅月价跟行事比例
它有一些缺点
假如发言商不想卖 报价会拉大
或者有时候会有降微买影波的问题
或者你会容易买到不合理的价钱
这比较麻烦
所以用股息來做純股
我是覺得比較好一點
是 你看小哥最近都不講權政
講純股了 你就知道權政也變難做了
對 權政呢
發行商越來越不給你甜頭了
因為這樣我們老實說
發行商這幾年來
被這些短線客修理得太厲害了
也是啦
因為他們程式交易太狠了
對
這個發行商有跟我說過
短線客一年賺1億
他說從發行商上賺1億
就是那种城市交易的
他们赚一亿发行上要赔10亿
因为他还有交易成本
还有避险成本
赔很惨
所以他们全镇就没办法造势的那么好
都是被短线课冲坏掉了
你啊
不是我
有几个城市交易的
我们没有
我们现在是手动交易
好
那期货呢
在期货部分呢
我们特别喜欢
最近有些股票
像有一股票
我不是做存股的
但是我喜欢参与一日行情的
例如说像鸿海
鸿海这个我每年都讲
今年也要配息了
历年配最高的一次
对 鸿海很特别
鸿海我们来看一下
它在除宣息当天
当天它上涨几率有到90%
你在第一季有稍微教过
对
90%什么意思
各位鸿海你一整年都没完
它没关系
你可以趁着在除息前一天买
买 财与除息
对 赌它隔天是收高
因为这10年来只要上涨
平均涨幅是2.2%
然后它10年有9年是上涨的
所以这种一日行情的也不错
那鸿海它不止当天是容易收高
它开高几率也有到80%
所以等于一开高你就可以
一开高看你要不要慢一点
然后收盘你再卖也更好
因为它收盘
通常收盘的价格都还不错
所以像这种都是玩短线的价差
所以股票起货
你可以玩短线价差
你也可以做波段存股
事实上它有很多好处
这种股票类似的
我们在待会的
荣耀班再跟各位讲一下
好 所以大家都以为小哥喜欢做短线
事实上小哥对存骨很有概念
但是叫做类存骨
因为是用个股期这个工具
请大家如果没有做过个股期货
还是要先了解一下这个工具的优缺点
再决定您要不要做
因为毕竟它是一个开杠杆的工具
好 所以如果小哥的标的的话
请大家参考荣耀班
我們等一下會來進一步的做解說
就最近小哥他認為還有哪些類存股的標的
今天非常謝謝小哥
在這個版本裡面有教大家
他的類存股的方法是用個股期貨
當然你除了評估風險之外
一樣你選擇存股的標的
第一個當然是有發行個股期貨
第二個就是一樣去評估
他是不是適合存有沒有殖利率
他的過去獲利是不是很穩定
不要去找那種高波動的
明明是做加剎的標的來做累存股
你會真的很累喔
因為你可能要常常去補你的保證金喔
好 希望今天的教學呢
能夠讓你在存股的路上
多一種工具喔
而且可以節省你的資金成本
好 那今天的歌有求必報就到這邊了
我們下次再見囉
掰掰